hola
[Música]
he venido pensando en una suposición qué
pasaría si me quiero una pierna pero no
lo suficientemente importante entonces
sigo con mi vida normal como si no me lo
hubiera quebrado sigo caminando
corriendo
atendiendo mi vida laboral personal
académica aunque por otro lado y muy
humanamente estoy re teniendo mucho
dolor ganas de llorar
frustración miedo de hablar de mi pierna
quebrada de no ser comprendido y que
cuando finalmente decido hablarlo me
encuentre con una abundancia de
soluciones acerca de cómo sobrellevar mi
fractura que si tengo buena actitud mi
pierna va a dejar de estar quebrada o
más drástico aunque yo elegí quebrarme
la pierna y por eso estoy en esa
situación dolorosa estando así como
sería dar el paso de buscar ayuda médica
y que no me atiendan porque mi pierna no
lo suficientemente importante y no es
considerada como una emergencia
todo esto suena
inaceptable
todo esto no pasa con una pierna
quebrada todo esto no pasa con la salud
física que es visible
pero conoce los 30
cotidianamente estamos expuestos a una
comunicación que pone a la felicidad
como un punto ideal para alcanzar y nos
hemos acostumbrado a silenciar las
emociones estéreo típicamente conocidas
como negativas invalidando por completo
que las emociones como la tristeza el
enojo o el miedo tienen una función tan
importante y que incluso sin ellas no
existiría el contraste necesario para
poder percibir la felicidad misma
justamente esto es una herramienta
comercial muy poderosa porque se
reconoce que somos seres emocionales y
se coloca la felicidad como un objeto
como una necesidad o como el título
perfecto para referirse al sentido de
vida o la autorrealización siendo esto
en realidad una búsqueda que se ha
planteado históricamente desde
corrientes éticas y filosóficas
partiendo de este punto diariamente no
se nos están presentando productos para
consumir sino sue los valores y
emociones que intencionalmente
necesitamos y eso nos lleva a que por
ejemplo implícita o explícitamente el
anuncio de una bebida nos dicte cuando
una manera ideal de celebrar la navidad
y el amor de familia la comercialización
de la felicidad nos hace entrar en un
círculo de insatisfacción la inmediatez
y el placer efímeros nos hace querer más
y más y más siempre y pues claro como no
frustrarse como no estar en búsqueda de
querer transformar nuestra subjetividad
para encontrar alivio
desafortunadamente es accesible toparnos
con alguna literatura de autoayuda o
contenido muy influyente que nos
responsabiliza absolutamente de nuestro
estado anímico de la forma
descontextualizada
generalista y sin un sentido de
intersección alidad por ejemplo con
frases que relacionan la tristeza con
falta de apreciación al paisaje o cuando
se dice que la felicidad es una decisión
entonces que están expuestos estamos a
placebos instantáneos que le pasan por
encima factores sociales económicos o
incluso
biológicos bajo que influyen si estamos
planteando nuestro concepto de felicidad
en nuestro concepto de éxito yo no me
cuestioné esto hasta que experimente no
querer levantarme de la cama porque ya
no le había sentido porque ni siquiera
poniendo todo mi esfuerzo en apreciar el
paisaje me emocionaba y porque
independientemente de mi entorno todo
giraba alrededor de las esperanzas o
mejor dicho no me cuestioné esto hasta
experimentar una depresión severa
diagnosticada por una profesional luego
de estar muchos muchos meses insistiendo
para tener atención psicológica y
psiquiátrica porque el té de tilo ya no
me hacía efecto empecé a ver el
contenido relacionado a la felicidad
muy distinta y definitivamente no
calzaba con ese ideal se sentía y se
siente como un insulto o planteado otra
forma se siente como una zancadilla
mientras lidió con mi pierna quebrada
sin mencionar que para un grupo social
en específico esto me convierte en una
figura ejemplar del concepto generación
de cristal y bueno mientras sentía que
mi vida cotidiana estaba totalmente
desmoronado y mientras lidiaba con un
auto estigma muy pesado escribir era una
de mis fugas de escape escribía mucho y
sentía que ese era mi estado emocional
real y a la vez
secreto porque me carcomía mi percepción
distorsionada acerca de la
vulnerabilidad en ese momento empecé a
escribir la letra de una canción que
compuse en un punto de quiebre sin
expectativa de compartirla algún día y
para mí era algo así como un diálogo
interno yo quería convencerme de unir
mis partes quebradas más que sólo
aceptarlo el quiebre y principalmente
quería comprender porque cada día tenía
menos esperanza para
asimilar que mi situación podía mejorar
mientras me pasaba horas y horas
buscando historias o testimonios con los
que pudiera identificarme y también
sentir que no solo yo estaba sintiendo
desesperanza empezó la pandemia sentí
que la había acelerado de funcionar como
una curita emocional y las cuatro
paredes el aislamiento
hicieron más evidente aún la crisis de
salud mental que ya está sobrellevando
pero principalmente y de forma muy
impactante no era una situación personal
chino mundial las cifras actuales lo
demuestran y son muy alarmantes según la
organización mundial de la salud cerca
en mil millones de personas viven con un
trastorno mental y cada 40 segundos una
persona se suicida cómo es que ha sido y
sigue siendo una crisis silenciosa
cómo es que se invierte en promedio sólo
el 2% del presupuesto sanitario en salud
mental siendo consciente de estas cifras
mientras intentaba desmenuzar el nuevo
pensamientos que tenía en ese momento
retomé la canción que había guardado por
más de un año y pensé
si esto que estoy escribiendo es
justamente eso que aunque sea una
persona necesita escuchar pasaron unos
meses y estuve sobre pensando y
finalmente decidí lanzar mi canción me
siento algo la compartí como un
testimonio personal un 10 de octubre el
día mundial de la salud mental y decidí
también hablar sobre mi proceso no
lineal y derecho actual con mi salud
mental y me empecé a cuestionar quién
pasaría si más personas hablarán sobre
cómo se sienten sin tapujos sin filtros
auténticamente qué impacto tendría esto
en nuestra sensibilidad en nuestra
empatía de nuestra percepción de la
salud mental a raíz de estas preguntas
de / la iniciativa me siento en costa
rica un hashtag que reunió testimonios
de personas con distintas realidades que
escribieron acerca de su salud mental
historias que se convirtieron en un
libro físico y qué civil izan de forma
vulnerable pero una vez muy poderosa
como es que muchas personas sobre llevan
su vida laboral académica personal sin
apoyo psicológico o psiquiátrico este
libro es un llamado a las máximas
autoridades de costa rica- la salud
mental debe priorizarse debe tenerse el
hecho que entre los jóvenes de 15 a 29
años el suicidio es la segunda causa de
muerte a nivel mundial que la evidencia
desatada en esta pandemia de esta crisis
silenciosa que estamos viviendo sea para
construir cambios no positivos muy
instantáneos sino cambios estructurales
pensando en priorizar e invertir en
salud mental de forma intersección al
que nuestra salud mental sea igual de
importante y urgente que una pierna
quebrada y que sea visto como
inaceptable si no se considera como una
emergencia y de forma muy lamentable y
dolorosa personalmente
y el libro me siento no llegue a
contener otro caso
ah
[Música]
estoy preguntando después de tanto
tiempo yo soy en mi cuarto porque hoy no
me dormí
siento a lo
sigo al ahora me siento a lo
que sigo preguntando después de tanto
tiempo
en mí
porque me quiebro así
sí no me siento
bien
sigo poniendo a prueba mi mente que no
todos los sólo tengo presente si está
quebrado y responder los datos donde doy
o frotó maipú recuerdo que me dicen son
win
pero yo duermo despierto camino y sigo
esperando sea light semanas tan largas
minutos son ahora las noches amargas
palabras del foro sé que está muy triste
yo busco la piel si está muy pesado yo
vengo a estar te recuerdo que me dicen
son wind país pero ayudar me despierto
camino y sigo esperando esta ley
tanto después de tanto tiempo yo soy en
mi cuarto porque no estás aquí
me siento mal
sí no
ah
sí
después de tanto tiempo
[Música]
porque nos llegan
no
con él
un mir isla tío me mire es company hoy
me sumerjo en que ya rompió la hiel que
gwyneth y no eres campeón y para seguir
amplia aunque tu quebrada este
en otros campos
la familia es company un mismo
[Música]
me siento tanto después de tanto tiempo
yo sigo en mi cuarto porque antes no lo
viví
siento mejor
sigo mejor me siento mejor
[Música]